hä was meine Heimatstadt soll die
hässlichste Stadt Deutschlands sein naja
komm da gibt's ja hässlichere Bielefeld
warte schon mal in Bielefeld die größte
Stadt der Region Ostwestfalen ist eine
trostlose Ansammlung grauer Häuser
mitten in den sanften Hügeln des
Teutoburger Waldes als sei er gut also
ich muss sagen wirklich schön ist es
dann nicht aber eigentlich also man kann
z.B richtig gut feiern gehen auch unter
der Woche und sowas wie Duisburg Hagen
Castrop-Rauxel alles in Ruhe Gebiet ist
eigentlich deutlich hässlicher sein die
Bielefelder mit ihrer Stadt nicht schon
genug gestraft gibt es seit einigen
Jahren auch noch allerlei Witze darüber
und es laufen unfassbar viele komische
Gestalten am Hauptbahnhof rum das stimmt
das Bielefeld eigentlich gar nicht
existieren würde dabei hat die Stadt
durchaus auch schöne Ecken Mann das habe
ich schon bestimmt also ohne Scheiß 3000
Mal gehört eigentlich jede Woche wenn
ich irgendwie sage ich komme aus
Bielefeld gar nicht